- Is it true that you have a thing?
I love this, that you've,
I've only been stuck in an
elevator once in my life.
Well, twice,
but you get stuck a lot,
and it's always with like famous people.
- I, when I get in an
elevator, I think, oh,
there's a one in three
chance I'm gonna get stuck.
I don't know why.
It just, I just get.
- So crazy.
- I've gotten stuck in
elevators quite a bit.
So I'm like really calm.
It's like, okay.
But my favorite getting stuck,
I have been stuck with
a few well-known people,
but my favorite was being
stuck in an elevator in Harlem
with Tom Cruise.
- That's so random.
- I know.
It was so random.
I was a publicist.
I used to be a publicist.
- Oh, wow.
- So I was a publicist for
a movie that he was in,
and it was he, him and me,
and we were in the elevator,
and he was so lovely.
We had a good, kind of, just
10 minute chat in the elevator.
- About like maybe how
long you'd be there.
- Yeah.
Just about how's this gonna go?
I said you have some good skills.
You can get us out of here.
Climb up on the thing.
- Yeah, where are you
now, "Minority Report?"
Yeah, absolutely.
- Exactly.
- He can like scale up
the shaft or something.
- If we needed it, I
think he could of, yep.
- [Kelly] I'm sure he could've.